Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number and
that number is two one nine two. David P.
A number of you calling in writing in about
this very question. This is from the eggman
who asks it so eloquently.
Speaker 4: Hey, do I have a pretty basic question?
Is the city of Kiev the one that used to be
called Kiev?
Speaker 1: Yes, Solow. Yes, Shalom to the
eggman. It is. So here's many of you wrote
to me because yesterday, during our coverage
of the Russian invasion of Ukraine, I was
talking about Keith and in the comments, as
well as an email voicemail. Many of you said,
Sir, what the hell are you talking about?
Isn't it Kiev? Here's the back story the spout.
It all stems from the spelling in English,
the anglicized spelling. For a very long time,
the capital city of Ukraine was spelled KITV.
And when you look at that, that very clearly
would make most English speakers say, Oh,
it's Kiev, that makes sense. It spelled Kyiv
and it's pronounced Kiev. Couple of years
ago, a number of media outlets, including
NPR, decided we are going to change the spelling
and the pronunciation to be more in line with.
In Ukraine, the spelling was changed to K
Y I V, and when you see K YV, most English
speakers would see that they would say, Oh,
that looks like Kiev, right? OK, so that's
what happened. The idea was, we've kind of
anglicized it away from what it actually is
in Ukraine. Let's try to match up with that
more so now it's it's a new spelling k y IV.
And it's a new pronunciation Kiev. Spell it
however you want it. Say it, however you want
it. And Russia has started executing a slow
invasion of Ukraine, as we covered earlier
in the program. So appreciate the eggman calling
in about that and appreciate the opportunity
to clarify. On today's bonus show, we are
going to talk about the history, and the history
is quite extensive of why Russian President
Vladimir Putin is obsessed with Ukraine. We
will also talk about. Why it's Ukraine and
not the Ukraine, OK? Saying the Ukraine would
be like saying, Well, anyway, I'm not even
going to get ahead of myself. OK, let's we're
going to talk about that on the bonus show.
We are also going to talk about the first
public option health care plan in the U.S.,
which is not getting the traction that we
had hoped. We're going to talk about its details
and we're going to talk about why. And then
lastly, if you have filed your tax return
and it's taking longer than usual for it to
be processed, et cetera, the IRS is dealing
with such a backlog and a worker shortage
that they are actively trying to hire more
people to actually go through that backlog
of tax returns and modifications and resubmission,
etc. And we will talk about how long it is
all expected to take. That's on today's bonus
show. Sign up on my website. Join Packman
dot com. You'll get instant access to the
bonus show. Also a reminder many live events
upcoming in the next week. Starting Thursday
evening, we will be live with C-PAC from Florida,
the Conservative Political Action Conference
Thursday, Friday, Saturday, Sunday. Donald
Trump expected to keynote CPAC, I guess, on
Sunday afternoon, and we will be live with
all of it. Monday, I will deliver my state
of the show address one day before Joe Biden.
Tuesday night will deliver his State of the
Union address, which we will have live on
YouTube, Twitch and Facebook. So I hope you
will join me for many, if not all, of these
live events. And in the meantime, sign up
it. Join Pacman dot com to get access to the
Daily Bonus Show for our members only.
Unidentified: I will speak to the.